[Musica]
nel 2013 prendere un caffè per me
significava esattamente questo prendere
un caffè al bar mi sedevo sapevo che il
caffè percorreva a centinaia di migliaia
di chilometri e finiva nella mia tazzina
nel 2013
la vita del caffè finiva nella tazzina
tutto questo però fin quando non ho
cambiato il mio punto di vista su cosa
significa sul serio prendere un caffè al
bar cambiare il punto di vista non è una
cosa che noi scegliamo non mi sveglio un
giorno e dico oggi cambia mio punto di
vista
no purtroppo non succede così io penso
che cambiare il punto di vista è un po
come innamorarsi ci capita semplicemente
senza poterlo scegliere ed io mi sono
innamorato del mio il nuovo punto di
vista su cosa significa prendere un
caffè al bar
oggi qui a genova al ted vi racconterò
come grazie a ted ho scoperto che una
linea può diventare un cerchio è quello
che è un problema può diventare una
soluzione nel 2013 sono architetto mi
stava laureando in architettura e
durante delle ricerche per la mia tesi
sono incappato in questo fantastico the
talk tenuto dal terza altezza loan di
londra da michael paul in un architetto
designer michael palin parlava di
biomimetica di come poter utilizzare la
natura per progettare architetture per
progettare oggetti per progettare opere
di ingegneria in maniera sostenibile e
in maniera naturale biomimetica è una
parola difficile che significa copia e
incolla dalla natura ovviamente noi
sappiamo perfettamente che la natura ci
ha dato un esagitato migliaia e migliaia
di esempi e tutt'oggi ci da esempi su
come progettare in maniera sostenibile e
in maniera razionale
un esempio su tutti sapete perché i
treni veloci hanno quel muso ingegneri
hanno scoperto che il martin pescatore
che è un uccello utilizza il suo becco
il nono maniera fantastica e pratica lui
aspetta sul ramo il pesce appena lo vede
si fionda una velocità impressionante
arriva in acqua e non emette un singolo
schizzo cosa hanno pensato gli ingegneri
perché non utilizziamo questo muso sui
nostri treni superveloci risultato treni
più veloci consumano di meno e quando
rientrano nella galleria ad altissima
velocità utilizzano molta meno energia
ovviamente possiamo ben immaginare che
gli esempi che la natura ci dà per
progettare in maniera sostenibile sono
molteplici
michael palin infatti ci fa tantissime
altre esempio in questo the talk che vi
consiglio anche di vedere ma la cosa che
mi fa alzare dalla sedia nel 2013 è un
piccolissimo intervento che michael
prende in considerazione lui ci parla
infatti di poter utilizzare non solo le
forme della natura ma anche e
soprattutto i processi naturali che
permettono a tutti gli attori di vivere
in maniera armonica l'un l'altro come
una foresta fondamentalmente lui parla
di blue economy ripara dic lo sviluppo
economi di economia circolare l'economia
circolare non è nient'altro che copiare
dalla natura i processi e portarli nella
nostra realtà e lui parlava
fondamentalmente di creare aziende di
creare imprese di creare nuovi posti di
lavoro che copiassero tal quale i
processi naturali
ovviamente pensare che la natura poteva
ispirare la progettazione di nuovi posti
di lavoro a creare nuovi lavori era
assurdo
a quel punto io dovevo saperne di più
dovevo capire come era possibile
riuscire a portare la natura in processi
antropici in processi umani come quello
appunto della creazione di lavoro e
dell'economia
internet ha fatto il suo corso
dovevo sapere qualsiasi posa su questa
economia circolare fortunatamente
abbiamo internet e digitando su un
qualsiasi motore di ricerca
sono venuto a conoscenza di questa
economia circolare l'economia circolare
esiste l'economia circolare reale adesso
viviamo in un contesto di economia e
lineare dove estraiamo qualcosa la
trasformiamo e la buttiamo in discarica
l'economia circolare invece ci dice che
gli output di un processo possono
diventare gli input di un altro processo
produttivo in maniera virtuosa
l'esempio che io che mi ha fatto
veramente impazzire è quello di un
ristorante
questo ristorante ha scelto di
utilizzare il 90 per cento della sua dei
suoi materiali utilizzando carta cartone
o cellulosa in questo sempre i piatti
alla fine della giornata il ristorante
non butta i resti di carta cartone e
cellulosa nell'umido o
dell'indifferenziata mari cede a
un'intera un maneggio che lo utilizza
per i cavalli come lettiera i cavalli
dormono anche se si dice che dormono in
pratica variano il bisogno delle
lettiere alla fine del processo appunto
quando i cavalli hanno utilizzato queste
lettere piuttosto che buttare lettieri
utilizzate
vengono cedute a un impianto di
compostaggio dove lombrichi utilizzando
le lettere per produrre compost
dall'altissimo valore nutrizionale per
le piante lupus di lombrico il compost
di lombrico e la ferrari del compost e
il compost dal più alto valore aggiunto
una volta che il compost è stato
prodotto i vermi l'accesso non vengono
smaltiti ma vengono ceduti ad un
impianto che alleva storioni lo storione
cede al caviale che viene venduto al
ristorante che lo serve né sui piatti di
carta che poi vengono date al maneggio e
così via
in pratica quello che era paul che era
carta che era cartone diventa caviale
qualcosa senza valore quello che era
considerato uno scarto diventa qualcosa
da un altissimo valore aggiunto ci
rendiamo tutti conto che un'idea del
genere e concepire l'economia come
economia circolare ci può aprire a delle
soluzioni infinite basti pensare che la
carta è diventata caviale ma dovevo
saperne di più e internet
ancora una volta ha fatto il suo corso
digitando un'altra volta economia
circolare su un qualsiasi motore di
ricerca vi renderete conto che ci sono
decine e decine di start up di aziende
di persone che hanno fatto dell'economia
circolare il proprio punto di vista
loro hanno capito che l'economia lineare
nella quale adesso noi purtroppo
sopravviviamo è ormai un sistema
obsoleto
deve essere cambiato a favore
dell'economia circolare
ora il problema era unico che io volevo
entrare in questa economia circolare per
me era l'unico modo reale di concepire
un sistema economico
l'economia circolare però non avevano il
ristorante e un maneggio non coltivavo i
vermi non avevo gli storioni quindi
avevo bisogno di un caso studi che fosse
vicino alla mia realtà e grazie a
internet
ancora una volta internet sono venuto a
conoscenza di un esempio fantastico di
economia circolare nel 1990 il
professore shooting chang
dell'università di hong kong un micologo
e di fama internazionale stava studiando
come utilizzare substrati alternativi
per la coltivazione di funghi
commestibili
ad oggi i funghi si coltivano con la
paglia o con lo stallatico e professore
shooting chang ha scoperto che altri
substrati potevano essere utilizzati e
il migliore era il fondo di caffè in
pratica shooting chang ha dimostrato che
dal caffè si fanno i funghi l'immagine
del professore con questo caffè che esce
dal suo cervello e con i fumi che escono
dall altra parte in mi ha completamente
invaso non so se avete capito ma io
vengo dalla provincia di napoli torre
del greco il caffè non manca i funghi ci
sono e quindi ho pensato ecco questo è
il mio caso studi quindi cosa ho fatto
ho studiato i funghi il professore
shooting chang mi ha spiegato come
funziona la vita del fungo è
innanzitutto quello che noi chiamiamo
fungo non è nient'altro che il corpo
fruttifero quello che noi mangiamo è la
parte finale il processo del fungo
quello che noi invece che a me che il
vero fungo e il micelio che una radice
che è sotto terra
però avevo bisogno di altre informazioni
e quindi internet
ancora una volta mi ha dato una mano
internet in questa storia ci sarà sempre
come vede ben visto e internet è la
chiave di lettura di questo mio nuovo
punto di vista del cambiamento che io
sto portando avanti grazie a internet ho
scoperto che coltivare i funghi dal
fondo di caffè era possibile lo stavano
già facendo altre start up
altri paesi quindi in pratica io avevo
il caso studi la realtà di napoli di
torre del greco
dovevo solo combinarle all'interno del
mio garage perché ovviamente non c'è
start up senza un garage
allora il 19 settembre del 2013
una data carissima i partenopei il san
gennaro inizio il mio garage la mia
sperimentazione quando dal bar del mio
amico claudio vado a prendere per la
prima volta il fondo di caffè
tutti ovviamente ridevano di questa mia
scelta
l'unesco al fondo di micelio al seme del
fungo chiudere una scatola e dopo
quattro settimane abbiamo questo questi
questi sono funghi freschi commestibili
coltivati dal fondo di caffè non sanno
di caffè ovviamente è la particolarità
anche per 100 grammi di prodotto
abbiamo 8,1 grammi di proteine sali
minerali e lovastatina le loro statine
sono dei veri e propri farmaci naturali
in pratica riescono ad abbassare la
pressione sanguigna e riducono la
l'assimilazione del colesterolo cattivo
all'interno delle nostre arterie
quindi in pratica io in un garage dal
fondo di caffè e il fungo avevo creato
un vero e proprio laboratorio quando ti
rendi conto che i funghi possono
convertire qualcosa senza valore
nutrizionale come il fondo di caffè e
farlo diventare proteine lovastatina ti
rende conto che il tuo punto di vista
sui funghi cambia perché io ho visto i
fondi da quel giorno come delle vere e
proprie macchine biologiche che riescono
con una frazione dell'energia necessaria
per produrre altri tipi di proteine come
proteine animali o altre proteine
vegetali i funghi appunto utilizzano
veramente pochissima energia
il problema ovviamente era questo che io
mi immaginavo un'industria formata da
produttori di funghi dal fondo di caffè
e ho pensato non è possibile che io sono
l'unico in italia che era impazzito per
questo tipo di procedimento e allora
internet
ancora una volta ha fatto il suo corso
ho scoperto che in italia c'è un intero
movimento di persone che fanno parte
della strategia rifiuti zero che pensano
che sono convinti e dimostrano che
l'economia circolare non è solo una
scelta ma è l'unica scelta è una scelta
obbligata che deve portare alla
sostituzione totale dell'attuale sistema
lineare di produzione su internet sono
venuto a conoscenza che in toscana
c'era un ragazzo che stava studiando
esattamente il mio stesso caso studi
stava utilizzando il fondo di caffè per
produce i funghi antonio antonio il caso
ha voluto che aveva avesse già fatto
innamorare di questa idea un
imprenditore giapponese che era qui in
italia manco a farlo apposta a investire
in start up dall alto valore tecnologico
ma soprattutto dall alto valore
ambientale
ho chiamato subito antonio non potevo
lasciarmi scappare questa opportunità
alla fine 2013 chi invia un'email e nel
antonio tumori rowe il sottoscritto
fondiamo la nostra piccola startup
agricola che produce funghi dal caffè
espresso e lo facciamo ad oggi in
toscana ea firenze il nostro lavoro è
semplicissimo tutti i giorni ci
svegliamo con le nostre biciclette
raccogliamo il fondo di caffè dai bar di
firenze che sono felicissimo ovviamente
di marcelo lo portiamo nella nostra
piccola azienda e trasformiamo il fondo
di caffè in funghi freschi da vendere al
mercato locale kit per la coltivazione
casalinga
e siccome rifiuti non esistono il nostro
fondo esausto lo utilizziamo per
produrci uno stile umbrico copiando
ovviamente l'idea di quel ristorante
noi avevamo creato con cinque step la
nostra economia la nostra piccola
esempio di economia circolare il
problema qual era però che fin quando
noi produciamo cibo fin quando noi
produciamo funghi e kit per la
coltivazione casalinga
noi lo stiamo cambiando veramente la
società la cosa che ci porta veramente a
cambiare il modello sostenibile il
modello economico da per delineare a
circolare è l'informazione
noi ci eravamo resi conto che il nostro
progetto andava oltre la produzione di
funghi
noi stavamo creando un messaggio stavamo
creando della conoscenza e ci siamo
domandati ma com'è possibile che secondo
voi una una società agricola non può
perché non società vigor non può andare
nelle scuole e fare educazione
ambientale perché dobbiamo sempre
aspettare che le istituzioni facciano
qualcosa
le stesse istituzioni che quando ci
hanno visto sono rimaste allibite noi
eravamo una chimera dal punto di vista
legale
noi siamo un'azienda agricola che non
utilizza la terra noi non abbiamo
neanche un ettaro di terra
la regione toscana per capire che noi
eravamo un'azienda agricola ha dovuto
creare una legge ad hoc e definisce la
prima azienda agricola regionale e senza
terra probabilmente siamo la prima
azienda agricola regionale
italiana grazie a questo significava
cambiare far cambiare il punto di vista
se le istituzioni avevano cambiato il
punto di vista allora eravamo pronti a
entrare nelle scuole a far cambiare il
punto di vista a chi veramente ci stava
a cuore i futuri cittadini perché sono
loro che dovranno poi adottare
l'economia circolare nei loro stili di
vita dopo dopo soli tre anni quel caffè
quella semplice tazzina di caffè è
diventata un idea è diventata un
business
noi produciamo non solo funghi ma
produciamo anche ricchezza che
produciamo posti di lavoro creiamo un
valore aggiunto da quello che era
considerato uno scarto e paradossale
pensare che il fondo di caffè che viene
considerato uno scarto rappresenta il
99,8 per cento della massa totale del
caffè l'espresso che noi beviamo e solo
lo 0,2 per cento lo 0,2 per cento va
nella tazzina
ogni volta che noi buttiamo il caffè
dell'immondizia
stiamo gettando il 99,8 per cento di una
pianta che ha polifenoli a carbonio
azoto limina tutti elementi che possono
essere utilizzati per produrre i funghi
questa questa storia di colonia
circolare ovviamente deve concludersi in
maniera circolare
siamo partiti dal tech talk di michael
palin che mi ha portato qui oggi a
genova a farvi di mostrarvi come
effettivamente è possibile cambiare il
punto di vista ed oggi siamo qui per
dimostrare agli altri che è possibile ed
è semplice cambiare il punto di vista
basta solamente fare un piccolo sforzo
basta solamente rendersi conto che
l'attuale modello economico lineare e un
è un modello obsoleto
noi siamo abituati a pensare in maniera
lineare ma ormai siamo alla è la luce è
alla portata di tutti il fatto che il
modello di economia lineare ormai ha
dimostrato i suoi limiti li sta
dimostrando e noi quindi col nostro
progetto vogliamo dimostrare che l'unico
vero modo di creare economia è quello
dell'economia circolare dove
non esistono scarti ma ci sono solo ed
esclusivamente risorse in questa in
questa in questi tre anni noi ci siamo
resi conto che l'unico modo appunto di
concepire
l'intero progetto è quello del cerchio
siamo partiti dal caffè siamo ritornati
al caffè siamo partiti da un ted e siamo
ritornati a un ted
tutto questo per di di cosa oggi è
quello che io vi chiedo è un ultimo
sforzo
sebbene sia normale pensare che l'unico
modo di concepire l'economia lineare sia
quello attuale io vi chiedo solamente di
fare un piccolo sforzo d'immaginazione e
di cambiare il vostro punto di vista la
vostra prospettiva
e pensare che quello che fino ad oggi è
considerato una linea può diventare un
cerchio e che l'economia circolare e
un'economia che si basa su un
semplicissimo e inconfutabile
una bella idea dove nulla si crea nulla
si distrugge ma tutto si trasforma
grazie